hey guys I'm Nikolaj coster-waldau
you're watching the wired autocomplete
interview
and I will complete some sentences now I
think who is Nikolaj coster-waldau Wow
that's to make this existential question
I like that well how much time do we
have
he's a Danish actor and he's best known
for playing Jamie Lannister on Game of
Thrones
who does Nikolaj coster-waldau look like
I think I was the first one who mention
it but the beginning of Game of Thrones
you looked like Prince Charming from
Shrek and also I've been told what's the
guy from the show lost yeah
I look like my mum as well who oh sorry
who's Nikolaj married - I'm married -
new Gaga and I've been married to her
for this June 22 years oh yes how do you
pronounce Nikolaj coster-waldau well
Nikolaj coster-waldau when I'm here when
I'm in Denmark it would be Nikolaj
coster-waldau see how much does Nikolaj
coster-waldau wait okay that's really
rude 93 kilograms which is probably just
200 pounds how old is Nikolaj
coster-waldau he's 48 how old is Nikolaj
coster-waldau swai she's 48 doesn't
think like us to Waldo know how to ride
a horse yes I knew how to ride a horse
prior to Game of Thrones but I did the
and there was a movie called kingdom of
heaven that really Scott did and I'd
worked with him on Black Hawk Down and
then they called and said you want to
come through this thing I said
absolutely do you know how to ride a
horse absolutely put the phone down and
instantly called like a place where I
could learn how to ride a horse okay
what language does Nikolaj coster-waldau
speak well I speak Danish English I
understand and can get by in the
Scandinavian languages can survive in
German and I once did a French movie by
accident I got a script from this this
this is called 24 hours in the life of a
woman and
I got the script in English and I met
the director and he said you want to
read the breathe scene and I started
reading a scene he said no no I saw one
set and I said oh I'm so sorry I don't
this is not gonna work and he's but he
still gave me the part so I did a French
movie poster in ski all a prophet beat
the diskens France Japan / / the phone
said mayor Mon petit / dysplasia dodge
it Festa Elizabeth Park in one mission
how was it how tall is Nikolaj
coster-waldau and feet he's just under
six foot two there's Nikolaj
coster-waldau and destiny - and I have
to ask what is destiny - okay I guess
I'm not I'm not in the investin II - I
play some games in life on my phone is
that the thing is that no is they go
like us - Waldo left-handed No Wow I did
it was the right hand but it was fine
you just practice what you left
why is Nikolaj coster-waldau name
hyphenated well I am I my parents
divorced and I wanted to have both my
mum's and my my dad's last name so I
hyphenated it and Nikolaj play a musical
can i play a music is that a is what you
want me if I say yes is that you then
want me to do it a musical instrument I
thought it's like should you want to I
can do cats I could play you know I can
play a bit of the guitar but yeah I can
say that safely there are no instruments
in here yeah I'm like every instrument
you know I can play anything
where is Nikolaj coster-waldau from he's
from Denmark where does Nick like us to
pull the lift
he lives in Denmark what happened to
Nicolai in Game of Thrones what happened
to nickel on Game of Thrones Nikolai is
an actor who plays a character he's not
really in Game of Thrones this is this
is fun why Jamie Lannister is the best
character clearly these are questions I
wrote myself I it's a great character
because he's I mean any character that
starts
and in the first scene more or less
having sex with his sister and tries to
kill an innocent boy that's a fantastic
starting point for like drama because
you can only hate a guy like that you
can only despise him and he's disgusting
him and then knowing that actually
you're gonna have to all that prejudice
you then pour into this characters
you're gonna be faced with that later on
when you find out that he's motivated by
some pure feelings of love and loyalty
and you know it's a very cool guy and he
can act like it'd be a bit of a prick as
well why isn't Jamie Lannister King well
because he's not you know that's I mean
that's that whole bloodline thing they
have in Westeros I haven't read the
books but I'll get back to you on that
one who saved Jaime Lannister from the
dragon that was bran played by Jerome
Flynn and we had a fantastic time
shooting as he was shot in in a place
called Catherine's it's in in in in the
west of Spain that sequence where the
Dragons come down and we worked with
these stunt teams and and the horse team
and and just too one of the things about
Game of Thrones is that obviously you
know the dragons and all the visual
effects are added but everything else is
is physical you see it so the stunt work
was insane
the writers they think you see 40 riders
standing on horseback just galloping
towards you it's pretty amazing but that
was not the question the question was
who's safe Jaime and that was wrong who
cut Jaime Lannister's hand off that was
a character kalach played by noah taylor
noah taylor broke my rib at Jaime's
captured by a lock and then they're
travelling towards I can't remember the
name on the way Jamie tries to escape
but he's then beaten up in this mud pit
and because I was in all this mud he's
supposed to kick me here and then he
missed kicked and then broke a rib who
could beat Jaime Lannister in a duel
well the questions should have been
before or after he lost his hand after
anyone could beat him but before no one
could Jaime Lannister beat our so a high
which is I think that chosen one or
something well he could could Jaime
Lannister be a Targaryen
you know it's Game of Thrones anything's
possible who did jaime lannister Squire
for he oh yes he squad for this famous
night called
Oh sir sir purse them sell me yes that's
the one you have to watch the show it's
all in there
how did Jamie Lannister get captured he
this is early on in Game of Thrones so
we didn't have that much money so the
big battles happen off screen this was a
battle between the Lannisters and the
Starks and Robb Stark captured Jaime
Lannister somehow as Jaime Lannister
redeemed himself well that's a good
question if you've just saved a million
people from being burned alive do you
have to redeem yourself I think not
where I did Jaime Lannister right off -
well you're gonna have to watch me today
to find out but I think his intention
was to go north what happens to Jaime
Lannister
you're gonna have to watch Season eight
to find out does Jaime Lannister change
actor what that's a great question I
don't understand him what is Jaime
Lannister's hand-made off it's made of
well if you watch the show it's made of
solid gold it is a metal hand that was
they did a cast of my hand and then they
it was absolutely beautiful will Jaime
Lannister join Daenerys well you're
gonna have to watch the show to find out
and that ladies and gentleman was the
end of the wire auto-complete interview
I'm sorry